should mandalorians ever become Jedi how
old is who Yang and what's thron's real
plan ahsoka's first season finale may
have ended on the mother of all
Cliffhangers but that doesn't mean it
didn't answer a few questions along the
way ah sooka season finale opens with
Morgan eleth being rewarded for her
service by the great mothers as all four
characters are night sisters it's only
fitting that Morgan's prize be dark and
magical in nature after receiving a
shadowy spell that gives her glowing
green eyes and a cool tattoo to match
her elders she's given another gift a
sword this isn't just any sword of
course the great mothers conjure it out
of thin air and when Morgan holds it the
blade ignites with a green
flame the
blade oh Talsen you'll recognize the
blade of talzin if you've seen Star Wars
the Clone Wars mother talin was the
leader of the night sisters for many
years right up until the end of the
Clone Wars or at least she was the
leader of the night Sisters of damir the
ones who dwell within the primary Star
Wars Galaxy it's difficult to say
whether or not talin would technically
outrank the great mothers and her age at
the time of her death was unknown
nevertheless some matriarchs clearly
respect her enough to give her name to
the sword they give to Morgan tzen only
uses the weapon once in the Clone Wars
in a duel with mace W so it must have
returned to the N sisters ethereal plane
after her death waiting for its next
Champion Morgan elth isn't the only
character to get a new blade in ahsoka's
final episode Ezra also forges a new
lightsaber for himself crafting the
weapon in hu Yang's Workshop the Droid
even provid Ides him with an identical
emitter to the one used by his old
Master Kanan jerus the shot of Ezra
igniting his blue lightsaber is enough
to make any Rebels fans a little teary
in the same scene Ezra seems amazed to
learn just how old Huang is the Droid
mentions that he helped Kanan craft his
own lightsaber on but when Ezra asks his
exact age hu Yang only responds vaguely
old enough to know that the relationship
between a master and an apprentice is as
challenging as it is Meaningful the
truth however is far Wilder the
canonical Source book Star Wars
timelines claims that hu Yang was first
powered up in 25020 BBY plating his
birth right around the same time as the
beginning of the Jedi Order that's right
Huang puts Yoda's ancient age to shame
in fact he actually helped Yoda build
his lightsaber when the little green guy
was just a little green youngling he
would have forgotten more about the Jedi
than anyone could ever know although
since he's a Droid he probably hasn't
forgotten a thing after Huang helps him
build his new lightsaber Ezra asks a
Droid what happened between a and Sabine
it's an enlightening moment for the
audience too as a rift hasn't yet been
explained in any official Star Wars
story ahoka became afraid that Sabine
was training as a Jedi for the wrong
reasons after what happened on Mandalore
if you've seen the Mandalorian or the
book of Boba Fett you don't need hu Yang
to tell you what happened on Mandalore
the planet suffered a genocidal Imperial
Purge that killed almost every
Mandalorian including sabine's own
family this L likely hit her extra hard
because as shown in Rebels Sabine was
ostracized by her family for years the
Imperial occupation of Mandalore forced
her baren to disown her and it took a
lot of work for Zine to forgive them and
accept them into her life again just a
few years later they were murdered in
The Purge working so hard to regain her
family only to have them Stripped Away
must have been devastating but ahsoka's
response is also interesting it sheds
more light on why she didn't want to
train Sabine and shows just how
terrified she was of losing another
loved one to the dark side after
reuniting with Anakin in the world
Between Worlds however she doesn't seem
scared of that anymore right before they
charge into a barrage of Star Destroyer
laser fire to try to stop thraw Ahsoka
as says R if he has any intel about the
mysterious Temple or the villain scheme
he says that unfortunately he has no
idea as approaching by himself was never
an easy task but in his denial he
actually reveals something quite
interesting look Thon found this place
woke up the witches rebuilt a Starship
the idea that Thon didn't just meet the
great mothers but actually woke them up
it's curious woke them up from what but
they in some kind of magical sleep were
they dead only to be resurrected by
their own necrotic Powers we know from
mother talzin and the other night
sisters in the Clone Wars of powerful
witches are capable of existing outside
the material realm it's so hard to
imagine the great mothers entering some
prolonged Slumber though that would beg
questions as to how old they actually
are arguably more interesting is the
larger implication of thron finding the
temple what else did he wake up
alongside the great mothers are those
casket shaped boxes piled high in his
Star Destroyer even more sleeping
witches or maybe something even darker
whatever the real answer it's apparent
that thron now has a full arsenal of
dark magic on his side you might wonder
what exactly Thon is fighting for at
this point the Empire has fallen after
all and the first order is decades away
from reaching full strength why does
this chest still fight for its Legacy
well ahsoka's finale offers a brief hint
of the answer to that question after
Morgan sends the night Troopers to hold
off Ahsoka Ezra and Sabine Thon ask her
if they realize that they'll die Morgan
claims that they were honored to make
the sacrifice for the grand amoral
it is for the
Empire the security of our galaxy if
you've read any of Timothy an Thon
novels this line probably Rings true
Thon has always been portrayed as
someone who believes that tyranny is
necessary in order to preserve order and
security this line is also likely a
reference to a more specific Galactic
threat the grisa geminy first appearing
in the Disney cannon in the novel thron
alliances the grisk are a race of brutal
conquerors from the unknown regions of
the main Star Wars Galaxy Thon initially
leaves his own home in the chis
ascendancy to seek out allies against a
grisa gmany his surch ultimately leads
him to a high station within the Empire
thron's line in the Ahsoka finale
suggests he might still have this
mission in
mind